then one more face to the women at the ptt
non
video at iavoloha eyes are no problem
with the advertisements at the large
bocage longue asia de get more people to
win the book i know this is fine
satisfied with me so lucky if the very
different kind of books  you know this
was beaten tous à Houssen fortune d'une
certain marque many goals a night
in sixty seven soloist defender 06 10
haslital to do my book is more of books
body history of capitalism which is the
big different with what ricardo aux
remarks sans  smell nineteen jul 5
saves could you because he has been
written by watering were mostly
critical speculation with my my work as
i think it was successful is because for
the first time it contains l'auto son
tommy kohle evidence and if you with
every  body care about which is money
money and inequality its consequence is
for the life of people the life of pi
paul goude strike the life of pi paul et
l'om à lui des noses divorce everything is
better the currency he is exposed to what  we
know that 1.6 its important part that y
never want life and this is it well if
you like you look at the world the
hittist shutters you are all you
know the estimate we have is at the top
one person to and soldiers  in the world
holland half of the wall street ows at
the bottom fifty people including a
young girl people mobilized
anyone out of the race is sure you to the
fact that in ternational inequalities
between countries
il fut look within country is it this beat
leaves extreme
it used  to be even more and i call you
take quand je suis là que l'ex with your
friends
thank you go the top one person of the
population sulks moon over sixty person
of tolerance and one of the major
discovery in my booky that if you lie  to
me josh fox world one more words to the
great depression and the new social'
democratic policies new sochaux life
is cole compromise that were adopte id
after this shock it's a peculiarity
countdown two to finally have more i quit
à bole distribute young girl
commonwealth now unheard of 5 dick and start
england in haiti now this night in night
is where there was new trends it world
rising concentration towards our ba which
is all calves the ofs
when committing to rent at 2.5 on  go
in european countries with the equation
which is in many people are asking et si
loïc the middle class chair in toto
wealthy that's going to bring in the
future is it gonnet expendables 2 9
bigger and big air middle class in this
very important person and the  answer is
nobody knows who does it depends on the
policies that which was probably week
concludes jean of my book is a light
brand fate while des death in the
twentieth century be ashamed believin
deterministic hic economic losail seen
kid yens it all depends on the the
policies that we choose
but if we don't have for more physical
coordinate the if we keep had a
showcase competition can she is to
attract companies to attract highways
will be risky the individual owns the risk a
particle in europe
where we keep you sing like  for in some
score prix takreem amber 800 luxembourg
gleeks scandal where we learned in
europe the largest multinationales
company is who were not even think the
statutory tax right of ten piercing for
their profit de 6 luxembourg the way one
person to person that in the hands of
small and medium sized companies are
ping elsewhere effective tax right the
company sony
thibault in this d'ericsson writings of
serious risk in the middle class feel
that there is more than the witch and
the medium sized company is more than
those multinationales zbx au sol  as
tracts will be here there is dead rising
and quality in europe there is continued
can't take proportion switchers a
complete contradiction louise hours
democratic bezy
we're still very far from their eyes
avenauds my book is not to the pessimists
ibuki things are waste or  regulate 10 bis
in the risk that we should we should we
should i think it's the myth takes just
willaya match all for 6
in
ways in at the top a person who
told us this lot of people because the world
is big planet seven bilgen worse for the
100 millionth person
these 26 million worse to save him from this
big boobs in 10 games more than you if
you take it  you take in terms of wealth
another terminal beauvais oise - 2
million
a dollar a star on hollywood
problem having sums which people for
wittelsheim idol paula according to gas
inequality women with him huy
limit zone is naze longue at the
different group china societies benefit
from gros seng globalization is
comparable to the speed the problem is when
the top weight group's rising am strong
times faster than the size of the
economies you can see that you have a
problem you cannot continue for ever had
some by this will have to stop in this
will stop
somewhere know where he will it stop
with what thieves like sunshine
commonwealth nobody knows no bail out in
the play it we win it to win it tout
pout collective regulate challenge this
way think we need to believe in market
for six a globalization nina  can't
the economy think we need at
the same time democratic jong so
everything changes everything one thing at 10 powerful
force 6 at everything in the right direction
and that blows books in the population
as beneficial to the wild wonders reset
if large group  seen the population son
are globalized shon does not work for
them that they will turn strong
nationalist shower wiltern
speaking from french with the rise of
the crisis is very serious here concern
those concerning the well and things people
explained william to make thing
globalization benefits our  reads everything
to the small group of any group the
population of this is possible ifri
adopt police here
this v8 particles in formerly located nolwenn
sweden among the witch within the world
and this as he also the moon the most
egalitarian comme cuisine the world
although inequality  has increased show
dignified when i am with sweden the past
twenty years we know it is still has
compères touzit yeah that because we
lose everything number of roses european
comme je suis dissard style petit
egalitarian society wcs social' model is
working titles et de  particles
failed to combine shon of youth for and
with her in like that and norouet
maurienne 204.5 pipolino feel that this
is like we sell by the glass history
warfare longtime sweden oise sortie
owner of norway may be norway le vizier
honor sweden the  hills un look racing
auj create inequalities witch mountain
can be kind of trouble in the key of no
one sweden di noia role riccione by you
know i don't care this match if you think
of the impact of oil in terms of
inequality in the world  today et i know
is create extreme inequalities one
particle in one the middle east which
sentheim harvey difficulty deal with my
my book for in stone saicourt total
education budget
i am there and j -pd which is the people
who else is one of the time the  less
than 10 out of income going to small
cannes am without population in the
gulf to we have you enjoyed kilometers
way express located chan where you have
been millions of young people of the name
tells you if the 'future' and then i know
jack billions of  dollars in countries
with our populations
un think this can create and how not in
the case of north west sweden
everybody's which you know this much
less a false problem of size if he
dared accumulation off
of angels millions of dollars in the
book of the world  population large as
cherry with little developing prospects
this is kill you like they think they
should give it to some kind of days
whole foods and want to fail to fail
take that ou d'activé goudineau sochaux
l'année du cash aux vins d'alsace  you
still lives itunes et you're still be
very rich savane authorize de l'ethnie
seriously d'être me say they do in the
very long gone the impact of becoming
blantyre can't we own the social
democratic values ​​use of norway as i
think the way you lie tickle of the
deep in two and a half year old jpy a
law ni to get to five in ten years of
the deep in the return for people
twitter in particular
object of the pit maguette sy and that the info
withdraws fifty people
domestic fuel production justin foreign
capitoline as pay by the rest of the
world elodie ci se situer jeunes rives
never seen that in history with 10
accumulated eating so much for noise est
relative domestic tweet
joxean labor force watts imm'pact in the
long run dry  so our one thing if
it doesn't have a chest burden so you
have to take some one in practice had a
very high like that sings to me tax on
very high tech are hybrid like so
it's you look so overall evolution'
system attack i drive say  that what
has happened in country light sweed
latute in all axolotl mor lô income
and middle income group she leaves asos
or havelock wall street show this good
in the long run et loire et nohain our
acronym thaksin hamilton her canvas in
people game 2.0  people and nosy be
very small and if you 14 hours country
in europe core of four like she's
like germany britten le look at the us
ou 4 french cowboy savane inheritance
tax in this country is the top weight
and very large inheritance not talking
of your hands  à Houssen motifs you leave
none of millions of the top right in all
of this country is right now is about
forty people
sometimes fortyfive symptoms fortyfive
n as i don't hear merkel cameron
sign that they want to do the ex we done
and go  to zoom to people n use his
are not very very left wing politician he
observes center center rail
indeed us high dont he use that the
forty nobody tuna taxes
written in japan they just right to
fifty five I am strong I serve
nobody you magnify the  one country in
europe large as follows witches italy
under berlusconi which little farewell to
people
it took four large as i am
ignorant of course the big one with in
sweden ford wind that as you feel that
has au relativism hall open economy or
off are competition  louise norway yes
this movie louise des mcsa you have no
choice and the stooges argument n'a dared
problem is that if you do that and if
you just for corporate tax and your
hands up with you people corporate
tax with the same arguments
and that's en  slope or pay for you
schools and your soul system you will
have to over tax to monks enzi
someone who will be the taxpayer any
case our new show typical is losc
it medium skill taxpayers davies is good
for job creation to over tax when they
a  medium what it is good like the
way we do in sweden you and your heads
up some of this should remain feel that
no body care about them
helsinki noesis general evolution'
towers death competition to attract ice
which binds wells income group and dust and
that each individualist that kind of
shop boys and losc il medium skill
group the descent i'm losing from
globalization because there poutine
competition yes emerging draw their
strength ifat the same time then tax
system then tax the system
eastwood forcing this day taxing leaves
people who  are more advantage and them
more writing in the long and that this
will of political count 7.661